[Music]
you
Zimmer and CEO of MGM Resorts welcome to
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
the industrialist dilemma thank you it's
my pleasure
so now you've been the CEO of the firm
since 2008 is that correct that's right
what are the biggest changes you have
seen in your business in the last decade
well I've been there 20 years and I've
been the CEO for 10 the the biggest
change is really going from a casino
centric model to a entertainment global
entertainment company and that is a it's
a conscious change it didn't happen by
happenstance but that's a major change I
think the second would be you know how
we've unified the company culturally we
were a company of disparate properties
different cultures different points of
view and we're really working well
internally and I think I'm proud of the
change we've made there and I guess the
last is evolving in non-gaming areas to
make us more relevant globally so you
think of your customers on a go-forward
basis in fact some of whom are gonna be
our students here later today how do you
need to interact with them differently
maybe then how you interacted with
customers in the past well we continue
need to understand technology the
industry has been poor relative to other
retail industries as relates to using
technology to its benefit we've allowed
we've actually proud of our physical
environments which really draw a lot of
people but in today's connected world we
really need to be more digitally aware
and in the future that's going to be
important for every demographic we deal
with but particularly for the folks
equal to me in this classroom because
they're gonna want to be able to do
everything they want to do on their
smart device and we're we're crawling
into that I think we're gonna make a
major leap forward this year the time I
spent with your team and understanding
MGM one of the things that I've seen is
you don't just have one business you
really have five businesses right you
have hospitality you have food beverage
you have entertainment you have
convention you know it's a very very
complex business how do you think of
those five businesses
working together and coordinating
especially as you move to a more
sophisticated digital infrastructure
well that's the unique part of our
business model I think is that ecosystem
of everything working together I don't
think any one of those businesses would
be as powerful individually as they are
collectively and being able to create
that integrated resort experience
instead of a hotel experience is really
the key to our business model and where
MGM is a bit different than the other
gaming companies is that we really only
feel we should be in markets where we
can provide that entertainment
experience well we're not in the
commodity based slot machine or business
for example and so which is not to say
that that's not effective for other
folks it's just I don't think that's
where we can deliver the most
incremental value so you recently hired
your new and first chief digital officer
that's right tell me a little bit about
why you made that hire and what are the
things that you're looking to do want to
go forward basis over the next several
years well I could say that you told me
to when you saw me last year but that be
only partially true because we were in
the market when we were chatting in
seventeen we had to find the right
individual in this individual Kelly
Smith 25-year vet well known he was
running the digital platform for
Starbucks yes I set it up in China he's
got you know the right kind of
experiences so we we knew we needed
somebody when you and I were chatting we
didn't want to just hire anybody and I
think we had the right individual and
we've given him a lot of money to hire
up staff up his department which really
was non-existent so why do we do that
because we recognize that yes we have
these experiences but if we can improve
the guest interaction through digital
then we're going to get more market
share so whether it's digital wallet
whether it's digital access into your
room whether it's working on you know
making your own reservations when you
want to do it or just saying you need
more
or whatever it is that you feel like you
know you when you do not want to have a
human interaction you do not have to
have it that's but we know that's
important and he's already with a man
announced this one yet but it's already
hired another person and he's well on
his way to creating quite a I think a
good organization how do you coach your
team to be balancing the move to
digitization but also the kind of the
service that you know MGM provides when
people come to Vegas and they want to
have fun and talk to people and feel
like they're being treated specially you
know I think you know the the personal
interaction comes naturally to my
employees I mean that's what they
they've been brought up in the
hospitality business that's what they
want to do the the other parts the
harder part getting them to to adapt to
an embrace technology so we've talked
about technology more in the back of the
house area how do we create use
technology to get people out of their
offices more to get them on the floor
more to streamline system services and
procedures we've done a really good job
of that in the back of the house we're
really having done a great job in the
front of the house yet all of the people
that that work for me know we need to do
that they don't know exactly how we're
going to do it I think the people we've
been higher and more recently will teach
us all how to do it I don't think it'll
be as culturally difficult to get that
change implemented as other changes
we've already done you know working
together more collaboratively not having
destructive conflict within properties a
lot of the change we've made you know I
think sets us up in in internally where
we have a level of trust with our
employees that we're gonna try to do the
right thing and and in change can be a
you know positive not a disruptive force
one of the new changes and we've talked
about this before you know you're a
global business right you do business in
Japan and China and around the u.s. we
think about Las Vegas where MGM's got a
obviously a very large footprint Sports
is becoming a big thing right you've got
the Golden Knights who would have
thought they would be in first place you
stole our Raiders right so the Raiders
are gonna come
and you know eSports is also something
right that is is increasingly becoming a
popular especially with the younger
generation how do you think about those
influences on your business and how that
shapes how MGM will be doing business on
a go-forward basis it's it's a single
greatest growth opportunity for Las
Vegas
let's take tonight's for example if you
get on StubHub 80% of the StubHub
tickets out there are for folks buying
from the city where the visiting team is
playing the Golden Knights imagine what
that could mean for us and what it
already means for us in terms of better
fan engagement more people coming to Las
Vegas
you mentioned the Raiders a couple years
but this year you know MGM this is
fairly groundbreaking for the first time
and in our history we own a professional
team we bought a WNBA team and called
them the Vegas aces and they start
playing with Bill Laimbeer as their
coach this year I firmly believe within
the next three years people will widely
consider Las Vegas as the sports capital
of the United States major sports bowl
games Super Bowl college and there are a
lot of reasons why it's easy to foresee
that now probably five years ago no one
would have would have sensed that but
all the perceived barriers between the
casino industry and the professional
leagues have broken down between the
NCAA and NCAA and my industry have
broken down and I think that it bodes
well for the whole town okay so if the
last decade was a lot of integration
ain't getting the properties to work
together as you said fixing the back end
and making that happen when you look for
the next decade what do you think are
the top two or three things that are the
biggest both challenges and
opportunities you've mentioned eSports
but what else kind of is on your mind
when you wake up in the morning from an
operational perspective you know I worry
a lot about cybersecurity I worry about
protecting our assets from a physical
security perspective that's an ongoing
concern so I'll always worry about that
day and night from a standpoint of
making Las Vegas relevant today and in
the future I have high confidence and I
think it's based on you know being a
student of Las Vegas prior to living out
there for 20 years and seeing how it is
really very nimbly changed itself over
many many generations um people want to
move to Las Vegas
we don't have stayed in income tax I
hate to brag on that here in California
but we are get collecting a lot of
talent it's it's an exciting place to
live now wasn't so much so when I moved
there and so we have to continue to do
what our founder taught me to do 20
years ago he he always said and this is
the genius of Kirk Kerkorian he always
said that at any time we can attract
intellectual and financial capital to
Las Vegas for ourselves and for our
competitors it's good for MGM and if you
go into everyday thinking that you want
your competitors to succeed you want
them to invest you want them to grow
because that'll help the destination of
which you're the dominant player then
you go into it not thinking it's
someone's gonna win someone's gonna lose
you go into it thinking we could
continue to elevate the destination I do
believe that's going to happen I think
of all the companies that we study in
the industrial dilemma MGM may actually
embody one of the greatest combinations
of physical and digital you know the
location and ever the entertainment and
everything else and now the next wave of
entertainment that'll be coming so I'm
looking forward to continuing to watch
and observe and learn and Jim we
appreciate your coming to Stanford and
helping us do the class today it's my
pleasure your time thank you
[Music]